what is this egg seriously what kind of
ridiculous monstrosity were raja and his
crew shipping around on their boat
taking up half of its space here is what
i believe to be the true secret behind
this gigantic egg and what it may teach
us about the final war of one piece and
why this little girl we met on skypia as
we now know probably the single most
important arc before the time skip might
be the sky counterpart to
on land in wano and shira hoshi under
the ocean on fishman islands there has
been a ton of speculation around this
throughout the years but here are the
two main theories that have emerged over
time and that you might be familiar with
so let me get you up to date the main
generally accepted theory is that the
egg on roger's ship is the ancient
weapon uranus
this is because the first time we get to
see this mysterious giant thing on board
of the oro jackson which is the name of
raj's ship is when he's encircled by
shiki's armada of powerful warships
shiki is a former member of the
notorious rocks pirate group that was
the main antagonist of the one-piece
movie strong worlds and even though that
wasn't canon shiki as a character very
much is and so this battle between shiki
and roger takes place in the special
chapter zero of one piece that was
released together with the movie and
unlike the film itself is very much
canon in other words a legit part of the
story and so in this legendary encounter
where roger's situation seems pretty
much hopeless cheeky reveals that he has
come for an apocalyptical weapon that
roger has allegedly found somewhere
during his journey two years before
reaching love tale the only strange
thing we can see on the ship however is
the giant egg and like a miracle a
sudden change of weather brings a storm
that helps the raja pirates escape this
helpless looking situation and so this
of course suggests two things the storm
is connected to the weapon that roger
has and the weapon is connected to the
only weird thing the egg and as you all
know an apocalyptical weapon in one
piece must surely be connected to the
so-called ancient weapons that were
created during the void century or
really simply egg equals apocalyptical
weapon equals ancient weapon and since
we already know about the ancient weapon
poseidon which is the mermaid princess
shirahoshi on fishman island and pluton
seems to be strongly connected to
momonosuke and wano we must conclude
that this egg contains some sort of
living creature that is the actual
ancient weapon uranus but as you will
see i don't quite agree with that
conclusion to 100 i think it's actually
even better than just that okay so the
ack is connected to uranus but what
actually is inside
okay what actually is inside it again
people have tried to narrow it down a
lot since poseidon is underwater and the
warship pluton on the water uranus which
is named after the greek god of the
heavens surely must be connected to the
sky or to put it simply inside the egg
is probably some sort of creature that
can fly in the sky one idea here is of
course that this could be the egg of a
dragon but not just any dragon the last
remaining dragon in the one piece world
remember the world of one piece used to
have wild real dragons in it hundreds of
years ago that the government wants to
revive so badly they put dr vegapunk
their absolute mega ultra super genius
on it who honestly did a pretty decent
job i would say when we see the one
dragon we have on punk hazard the
celestial dragons as their name suggests
also seem to have some strange
connection to this mythical being making
the hoof of the dragon their actual
symbol there is of course luffy's
mysterious father monkey d-dragon the
leader of the revolutionary army and
with kaido and momonosuke we have not
one but two mythical devil fruit users
with real dragon powers that are not
only incredibly powerful but also hold a
special meaning as we now know big mom
found this fruit for kaido on god valley
that used to belong to the celestial
dragons in other words if this egg held
not just a devil fruit version but an
actual real dragon from the past
that would truly count as an ancient
weapon in my books at least with the
abilities to change the weather and
create destruction just like kaido has
been kindly enough showing to us all
throughout mono so far a really
interesting feathered alternative to
this that i've seen discussed here and
there as well recently is that this egg
might be some sort of mythical bird the
rock comes to mind for instance a
gigantus and legendary bird from middle
eastern mythology that also made its
debut recently in the story in chapter
1000 as luffy shows off his new big
attack as i've been told there are also
a number of legendary birds in filipino
mythology like the manaol or the concept
of the cosmic bird crater by the way
salamatpo to all filipinos who are
watching right now and then of course
there is the powerful giant hawk from
nordic mythology that sits on top of the
world tree yikdrazil and yes of course
we will also talk about elbaf and shanks
in this video in just a second as well
before we move on though a quick shout
out to elisa rosales solis and rocky
alonso both of whom are subscribed to
the channel and thus have helped me
increase my bouncy by 100 berries each
pushing me forward on our quest to
overtake treble's bouncy and reach 100
million berries okay so these are
basically the most common ideas so far
about the giant egg that are floating
around on the internet that at least i'm
aware of and they will be important to
what i'm about to tell you next but i
want to take things a little bit further
even now or actually a lot further
because i think that there is even more
we can conclude about the egg and the
ancient weapon uranus than just this and
it's all thanks to the incredible reddit
user acaore who posted a really unique
and awesome discussion about this on my
separated wild anime theories that
basically is just wild one-piece
theories at this point so make sure to
check it out if you're interested the
core idea here that i found incredibly
intriguing honestly is that the ancient
weapons aren't just one thing like just
shirahoshi by herself is not poseidon
momo by himself is not pluton instead he
proposes the ccc theory ancient weapons
consist of three parts three seas a
conductor that controls the weapon and
functions as a sort of he a carriage
that basically is the body of the actual
weapon itself and the cavalry powerful
beings that can carry and pull the
vehicle and the weapon and move it
around now this idea is especially based
on what we've seen about poseidon on
fishman island shirahoshi is poseidon
because she's able to command the sea
kings the giant sea monsters that rule
over the seas of the one piece world
shirahoshi seemingly has inherited this
power through the royal bloodline from
the last mermaid princess that lived 800
years ago the one that joyboy made his
promise to in other words the he to
unlocking the true power of the ancient
weapon uranus seems to be genetically
encoded into the royal family of fishman
islands the fishman being a race that
was part of or at least had really close
connections to the ancient kingdom by
the way this is pretty incredible like
this hints at how technologically
advanced that civilization actually was
and how hard it fought for a free world
in the future and so the third piece of
the puzzle here is the enormous ship
noah that we saw parked in front of the
islands a boat of absolutely
unfathomable size that dates back to the
void century and under no circumstances
can be destroyed until it can finally
fulfill its purpose i think i probably
wasn't the only one that got reminded of
pluton when they first saw this thing
and so i would argue that the noah is
actually part of the ancient weapon
poseidon you have the conductor
shirahoshi who controls the intelligent
sea kings who can pull this gigantic
boat something we actually saw them do
by the way like they actively made sure
that noah is safe this seems to suggest
that all three together form the ancient
weapon itself let's take it even a step
further you've probably heard about the
idea that at the end of one piece the
red line and the grand line will be
destroyed to form the legendary sea the
all blue well wouldn't pluton be the
perfect tool to get the fishman and
fishman island to the surface since
their country that is located directly
under the red line would otherwise be
crushed and buried and of course there
most likely would be some other military
use for the weapon as well obviously so
shirahoshi and fishman island have given
us the basic idea for how the ancient
weapons might operate as three parts put
together let's apply this to the ancient
weapon we know the second most about
probably fluton as we now know pluton is
located in guano we also have long
suspected that momonosuke is an ancient
weapon as well who is able to control
the gigantua's intelligent elephant
zunisha who once again dates back to the
void century and has a good relationship
with joyboy in some sense we also know
that pluton has actual physical building
plans these are the ones that tom and
iceberg passed on to frankie and that
frankie then burned in front of
spandam's face they were the entire
reason for zp9 being stationed in water
7 for all these years in the first place
so there is an actual physical ship or
object that can be built that is part of
pluton so once again the three c's match
perfectly we have momonosuke the
conductor a key that can be genetically
passed down from the void century
through the bloodline in this case of
the kozuki family that just like the
fishman were allied with or part of the
ancient kingdom and joyboy another
genetic key which like let's be real
here engineering the ancient weapons to
activate at a specific time only being
usable for specific trusted people it's
pretty ingenious by the ancient kingdom
you gotta be honest you have zunisha who
just like the sea kings can be
controlled by momo the cavalry who can
pull a physical warship the carriage for
which frankie had the plans and that
seems to be hidden away in or most
likely under wano itself i mean this
would also explain why momonosuke said
that he can't die under any
circumstances after reading about
himself in odin's journal and why he
wants to keep juano's borders closed for
now that's because he has to wait for
the right moment that he shira hoshi and
the third person that i'll get to in
just a second will meet and help luffy
slash joy boy to save the world after
all both momonosuke and shirahoshi were
inspired by luffy became his friends and
wanted to become as strong as he is
which finally brings us all the way back
to uranus and the giant egg on roger's
ship the gigantus living thing inside of
it would basically be the sky
counterpart to the sea kings underwater
and zunisha on sea level in other words
the cavalry able to carry the actual
ship part of uranus
but what about the conductor and the
carriage well since it's the sky version
of the three ancient weapons i think a
lot hints towards the sky itself where
as we know sky islands do actually exist
the reason i really like the idea of the
nordic mythology bird that sits on top
of the world triactra zeal inside the
egg is that our next goal in the story
is most likely elbaf elbaf not only has
a giant tree inspired for sure by the
tree drazil itself but it also seems to
be protected by shanks who is full of
nordic themes himself and so since
shanks was actually part of roger's crew
he might protect elba for exactly that
purpose now i do think that the giants
of elbaf were also allied with the
ancient kingdom and joyboy and there is
a real chance that the conductor
counterpart to shirahoshi and momonosuke
is someone from the royal family of
elbaf however there is a lot more
evidence that point at another ancient
race here the shandorans of skypia the
proud people who lived in the golden
city with its golden bell and the
poneglyph that talked about poseidon on
fishman islands skypia that as you know
from the big uder run theory i did might
well have been the actual location of
the ancient kingdom itself but then what
does elbaf have to do with the sky
islands right well as you might remember
the straw hats took the
unofficial route to the sky islands
using the knock-up stream however there
is also an official way to reach skypia
and i'm neither the first nor the only
person who strongly believes that the
giant tree on elbaf might actually be
just that entrance that might have the
giant bird from roger's egg sitting and
waiting on top which would then leave us
with the two questions who is the
conductor and what is the ship but what
if i told you we have seen both already
don't you also find that annal's arc
maxime is a bit of a curiosity in the
entire story enel is not exactly
portrayed as the brightest lamp in the
socket and so it's really curious that
he managed to come up with the concept
of the arcmix scene only that we know
that enel did not build this ship
himself but forced god's men the people
of skypia sworn to the person who holds
the title of god to build the ship for
him and so isn't it much more likely
that instead of nl being a secret
engineering genius he found the plans
for the arcmag scene in god's room
similar to how there are plans to the
pluton remember this is a ship that is
capable of traveling goddamn space
especially with luffy slash joy boy
being sun god nika who by the way was
first foreshadowed exactly here on
skypia wouldn't it make sense that the
title of god originally belonged to the
sun god slash joyboy the original
creator of the three ancient weapons in
other words isn't it much more likely
that the arc maxime is the ship part of
the ancient weapon uranus whose plans
got passed down among the sky people for
many generations which then only leaves
us with the person to control the giant
bird to carry the ark and complete the
ancient weapon and that very person is
most likely this little girl here isa in
case you forgot this girl allegedly was
born with incredibly overpowered
observation haki being able to hear the
entire skypia archipelago but does this
really make sense a kid who is born with
overpowered haki doesn't this remind you
much more of momonosuke hearing
zunisha's voice for the very first time
isn't it much more reasonable to assume
that this little girl has the voice of
all things like luffy like momo and like
shirahoshi and just like momo and the
mermaid princess isa was saved and
inspired by luffy it's an arc and
relationship with luffy that's exclusive
to these three kids only to them and
while we don't know who isa's parents
were we do know in fact that the
shandorans have a royal bloodline just
like the kozuki or the royal family of
the fishmen that could carry that
necessary key gene necessary for
awakening the conductor which in the end
would give us people from the sea from
the land and from the sky a creature
from the sea the land and the sky as
well as a ship for each of the three and
since we're most likely going to albath
and the top of yggdrasil next it would
be very easy for oda to bring isa back
into the story that way and so if you
want to know what else might happen on
the island of the giants and what has
been foreshadowed you really shouldn't
miss out on this video about albef right
here next